hey guys it's Tuesday October 27th I'm
Mary Kish and this is GameSpot news we
have all the good announcements from
sony's press conference mixed with a
little bit of fallout 4 news let's get
started first up there was a fallout 4
leak that showed the Xbox one control
scheme including new abilities with
under two weeks to go before fallout 4s
release the RPGs manual has repeatedly
been uploaded to the Xbox SmartGlass app
revealing the game's default control
scheme new abilities and more as
detailed through these images fallout 4
Xbox one controls include new options
for bash attack and sprint among other
things grenades are now thrown by
holding RB while pressing lb will bring
up the vast shooting screen check out
the article on gamespot to see all the
different default controls next up the
creator of Raymond showed up at Paris
games week to showcase a new gameplay
demo of ps4 exclusive wild Rayman
creator Michelle on cell took the stage
of Sony's Paris games week press
conference to present a gameplay
demonstration of his upcoming ps4 open
world survival game called wild gameplay
seems to revolve around controlling a
magical shaman who can use his powers to
take controls of various animals like an
eagle a rabbit or even a raven he can
also tame animals for his own use like
being able to write a bear for faster
travel through the lush green landscape
seen in this demo first announced at
Gamescom 2014 not too many details have
been revealed about wild until now
finally Paris games week revealed an
image for street fighter 5 teasing six
new characters today during Sony's Paris
games week briefing street fighter 5
producer Yoshinori Ono announced that at
least six new DLC characters are coming
to the fighting game beginning in 2016
he didn't reveal their names instead
capcom released this mysterious
silhouette image you see these six
characters whoever they are will be
unlockable either through gameplay
or via micro transactions in fact all
street fighter 5 gameplay DLC will be
free providing you're willing to play
enough there's no confirmation but we're
guessing the first one might be Alex the
middle could be possibly jury or ibuki
and the far-right possibly deadly or
Balrog who do you think the mystery
characters are let me know in the
comments below capcom also announced
today that Street Fighter 5 will launch
in February 2016 across ps4 and PC in
addition the character dhalsim has
joined the roster so that's all the news
I have for you today you can go back to
playing halo now unless you haven't
bought it yet in which you can check out
Mike McCarty's review it's on gamespot
now see you tomorrow